vingt-cinq ans après la grande famine
plus de 5 millions de personnes ne
subsiste encore que grâce à l'aide
alimentaire
l'ethiopie vient même de demander en
urgence 80 millions d'euros à la
communauté internationale mais alors
pourquoi brader des terres aux étrangers
si on n'arrive pas à nourrir
suffisamment son peuple pour trouver une
réponse
nous nous rendons à addis-abeba la
capitale le siège du pouvoir
officiellement le pays est aujourd'hui
une démocratie
officiellement seulement car en réalité
il s'agit d'un régime autoritaire
l'un des plus sévères d'afrique
[Musique]
nous avons rendez vous avec le ministre
de l'agriculture tafara d'air bio
bonjour merci de nous recevoir monsieur
le ministre c'est lui qui attribue les
terres aux étrangers
d'un côté vous avez plus de 5 millions
de personnes qui dépendent de l'aide
alimentaire et de l'autre vous bradez
vos terres aux investisseurs étrangers
beaucoup fait ça justement on va moins
dépendre de l'aide alimentaire grâce aux
étrangers c'est grâce à ces fermes que
des millions de paysans vont s'en sortir
ça va améliorer la qualité de vie des
gens notre seule richesse ce sont nos
terres
alors on fait quoi on attend que nos
paysans développe ses terres d'ici 30 à
40 en sortie full tilt ou alors on les
cultive dès maintenant grâce aux
étrangers c'est important que ces terres
soient cultivés le plus vite possible
mais quand on les interroge sur le sort
des paysans expulsés sans aucune
indemnisation de l'état
voici ce qu'il répond on vous a mal
renseignés vous êtes allé voir une
poignée de fermiers qui se plaignent et
qu'ils sont paresseux et qui ne
travaillent pas assez
c'est peut-être pour cela qu'on leur
donne rien parce qu'ils sont inefficaces
donc les paysans qui se plaignent sont
feignants
c'est ce que je crois oui à fenêtre j'ai
rencontré des paysans éthiopiens qui ne
sont pas feignant et qui gagne la
plupart du temps 11 euros par mois et
qui n'arrivent pas à vivre avec ça ma
question sans vous manquez de respect et
la suivante
ne pensez-vous pas que vous êtes en
train de laisser les étrangers exploiter
votre peuple
non ne laisse pas notre peuple se faire
exploiter
on essaye de créer des emplois vous ne
voulez pas imposer un salaire minimum
comme c'est le cas dans la plupart des
pays du monde les marques et distincts a
et d laissons le marché décider le prix
de la main d'oeuvre
avec cette politique volontariste
l'ethiopie espère devancer ses voisins
et devenir le pays africain le plus
populaire auprès des investisseurs
[Musique]